80s and 90s this was the most terriblest
place in brooklyn
the [ __ ] murder capital east
new york this place is huge two other
buildings on the other side
right on that corner i got shot if they
kill your son you don't understand why
would they do it this sunday the speech
depression event people respect violence
that's the universal language what if i
came in here alone with the camera what
do you think let's let's get what you
think
you're hanging around
you fall for everything you stand for
nothing but there's always respect i
give that out first peter you gucci one
last question what's the neighborhood
needed
good afternoon guys here in new york
city a city of many different worlds
today we're going to get into a world
that most of us are unfamiliar with that
is the projects
i had some locals reach out to me
living in the projects in brooklyn
saying hey peter do you want to get
inside the projects do you want to see
what it's really like in our world uh do
you want to hear our stories
so i thought
what not a better idea
so today we're off to the projects in
brooklyn should be an adventure like
most of these i have no idea what i'm
getting into
let's go
the subway stopped one stop early
so i gotta walk a bit
this is docher street
ave
we have public school 159
bars on the windows i don't know if
that's to keep kids out
or keep them in
in my school days
those bars would have been there to keep
me in because
i didn't like school so much
okay interesting neighborhood
interesting neighborhood mix of
residential
and some
small businesses mom-and-pop shops
thinking there he is there's the man
cashmere
thanks for eating up
quite possibly the coolest name i've
ever heard yeah
i'm smooth so they said that the hood
moniker monitored me with that name man
we're in new york man
chilling with peter santanilla
got to get it popping man
you're better than me at this you had a
good inch i think your intro is more
solid than mine east new york we out
here you see the t-shirt i mean the
sweater you're going you didn't bring me
one oh um actually i got one for you at
the crib all right that's school milk
that's that school milk my boy celie um
this is the project this plaza we're
gonna take him up on plaza first i'm
gonna go get me a vape we're just gonna
go right up there get it first yeah and
then we're gonna go up to the plaza the
legendary linden plaza and then i'm
gonna take him over to cypress hills
the [ __ ] oh yeah part of it all
right
as well you know i mean cypress hills
projects but you know y'all know me east
new york's finest man east new york is
um gritty of brooklyn the grit the grind
is where people don't come okay you know
you see everything getting gentrified
they ain't touch over here yet yeah i
don't see any starbucks going into the
neighborhood touch over here yeah it's
nice though you got good uh mom and pop
shops you know
if i had some hair i'd give them a try
but yeah this is coco
how you doing man this guy's great from
yeah
wait you said you're going to take me to
yemen yes hopefully yes i would love to
inshallah
see how it's a small world man that was
my god right here in the small world
show me that cashmere you have just uh
we just got ice cups like something for
the for the liquor they know we need ice
cubes for the liquor so i got me a small
bottle of cavacio i mix it with the
grapefruit and i buy my ice cube man get
out you guys what we do so you guys uh
you got a party going on right now or
what's going on uh nah we just gonna um
go to linden plaza
and you know they uh playing dice
regular day in the hood regular day in
the hood stuff
so what's uh you guys got a lot of ice
cream trucks here
[Music]
sutter and lincoln
this is building five the legendary
thrilled in five why is it legendary
this is life
there's a lot of legendary cats come out
of this building
[Music]
what are we saying yeah this is building
five this is um
the five buildings so is it back at the
beginning how are you doing
so everyone's mail comes to their to
their building here yeah it's pretty
nicely set up it's about 18th floor in
this building right here 18 floors yes
how many how many apartments sorry i'm
not sure how many apartments on each
floor i should know that but i'm not
sure but it's 18 floors 2026.
there's a lot of people in here yeah
there's a lot of like thousands huh
[Music]
so you guys know a lot of you guys know
each other well one time i could say
yeah i've been here 42 years 42 years
but transition death all those things
take people out of the realm
you take the stairs
[Music]
so are there different types of projects
like some are nicer than others yeah
this was considered one of the nicer
ones computer compton and all of that
and everything everything's okay if i
got the camera going yeah all right
is this guy a legend here
yeah what's good is that this is the um
you know peter you doing we're doing
real yeah how are you doing good what's
your name
my boy how you doing
peter
all right you guys got a good zone out
here huh
this place is huge yeah 18th floor she
said 26 minutes all the way
down there
walk me through what's going on here
every day every day a dice game young
boys chilling going right there
like everybody like me
you know it's legal now so we smoke it
outside
gumbo runs
so we just chill
bob i'll get drunk sometimes
this is just like
this to us like we grew up here our
whole life so yeah it's good to see your
friends so we just stick around we stay
close to each other oh here's your dice
this is where you're playing
two other buildings on the other side
it's all part of the same complex yeah
you need to cross the bridge
it's massive here you can't know
everyone so you don't know the guys way
over there probably yeah we're talking
about all buildings yeah we know
everybody we know everybody all of us
everybody knows so there's there's no
conflict between buildings
certain projects against complex this
complex now this come like fight it out
or whatever but we ain't really killing
each other like that like that okay yeah
that's that's kj bowler's memorial they
have one each year
he had passed away through the gun
violence right there on bradford in east
new york
and they celebrate his life every year
he was a young talented dude that really
did his thing that really rep for the
hood and
he passed away through the gun violence
so
we celebrated his life every year
hey wait that's new news to me guys so
this is this is not the project no
[Music]
it's probably good
complex
so what's the difference of complex and
projects
like what i told you earlier this is
plaza and then i'm gonna take you to
cypress yeah that's right that's the
project okay okay all right that's the
project this is they consider this a
project but we know what it is we don't
yeah you know i'm like uh i had a
thought of what projects were and i
didn't think like nice hosta plants and
you know
beautiful trees and whatnot
is it different at night
it's very different than that you know i
mean the cops is up here constantly they
up here monitoring people they up here
tripping they up here uh watching
everything that's going on man
you know what what do people think of
the cops here
or tough to say
i always ask that question
i'll be honest with you it's like [ __ ]
police up here okay but but um
you know the the elders need the police
man they you know the elders yeah they
need the police shout out to the all the
good police that ain't trying to uh
you know
damn
we're gonna go to this side cause they
didn't lock that off but shout out to
all the police that ain't crooked right
on that corner i got shot where'd you
get shot i got shot right on sutter and
lincoln
um
on your body i got shot in my leg uh
okay the bullet holes right there it's
still lit
you know i mean if you want to see it
you can see it oh sure yeah the bullet
hole i mean if you want if you're all
right the bullet hole right here
right there okay
the bullet hole right there
and i got shot when you go to cyprus
there's a whole it's a whole different
different being it's a whole different
realm you know poppy probably wouldn't
even took you to cyprus you know what i
mean but i could talk he's the guy that
like my boy pop shout out to pop but um
shout out to pop yeah shout out to pop
but i could take you to cypress because
i've been there done that papi that's my
that's my brother man shout out to his
father our son like his father our son
really held me down i was facing like 10
years in jail i did a year
shout out to my lawyer he he got me free
and i did a ton of programs do two get
free it was my first felony
and you know when i came home his pops
really held me down and really hold you
down what do you mean gave you guidance
uh he he he gave me yeah basically he
gave me guidance and put me in a
situation to where i could get a little
money so i could be out here doing my
thing and to prosper a little bit and
come up so you know what i mean that's
that's can do brother
[Music]
and pops left met rather my grandmother
used to have a uh apartment in 485 where
my pops used to live we used to hang on
these buildings i used to duck shots on
these buildings
bullets oh running this building ducking
bullets and this i ran in this building
my mom looking for me
because we we we ducking bullets and i
don't ran in that building and my mom's
like where my son at and i'm looking out
the window while my mom's like calling
for me and stuff like that is this the
real projects right here this is this is
the gutter
so when you say the gutter like okay i
don't know anything i'll admit it i know
nothing okay it's like
okay it's sort of nice to walk around
it's sort of nice to walk around yeah
it's nice to walk around because you go
walk around because you're walking
around with somebody that's legit out
here i was born and raised out here what
if i came in here alone with the camera
they gonna watch you look at me like
this i'm watching and see who's this guy
what's he doing why is he doing it is he
police is he this is he that but right
you know
you robbing with me if you vibe with me
it's all good man if you look at the
history you know the back always fought
against the front the middle was in the
middle so they wait wait back fought
against the front what do you mean this
is the back me in the back of cyprus
this is where i grew up at then you got
the middle right there you got the
middle right there and then you got the
front on the other side and the back
used to always beef against the front
they
they watching my my guy watching he see
some guy with the camera and walking up
he's like what's going on so you know
the alarms get set off immediately but
at the end of the day you know it's all
who you're with yeah basically let's
check it out we're walking up here
that's somebody that recipes 80
you know
is it already
yes film that circle rest a piece
he was a young young dude that passed
away recently and everybody loved him in
the hood you know
you need some help
you got it
yeah
there we go
yeah
yeah i'm gonna try to go into the place
where where my father was
was uh born and raised up on the second
floor
but
all right so what just happened is the
young guys were just basically just
basically on alert
yeah
which they're supposed to be yeah and
that's what's up but you know i'm going
to raise here so
it's just another thing to me
you think we can get into a place or
maybe not you don't know anyone here
right now we can see
okay
basically what happened i didn't explain
it well enough right the guys were out
there wondering who the hell we were
yeah um and you had to show them your
affiliation with other people yeah
gotcha yeah that's it how you doing
um unfortunately we couldn't get into
cashmere's childhood apartment okay 2f
that's where my family was at my father
my grandmother my heart my father
banging here um he got killed probably
like four or five years ago and then
when when they started getting crazy out
here my father told my moms not to bring
us out here to cypress hills to bat
because it was getting real violent
drugs was prevalent and guns
nah that's good that's good that no
that's cool that's cool i respect it no
is that
my grandson was killed
in 2018 2018 and ever since then it's
been kind of calm out yeah
he like brought people to the community
together
to bring the community together
they wanted to put uh um
like a sign in his name like a street
uh-huh
but i was too
out of it
yeah i couldn't meet with anybody at the
time you know yeah he passed in 2018.
yes sir
a day after his birthday yeah
and he was only 16 years old and
you just don't understand when you don't
when you don't expect it for somebody to
kill your son you don't understand why
would they do it
you know he wasn't in gangs he wasn't
internet and wrong
everybody he helped people right
anything he could help people
he's a real angel
yeah
what's the what's the solution to this
stuff do you think
right
um
to the violence to the shooting like
i don't know they think i don't know if
i really agree with police reform yeah
but
i know some of the police some of them
but all of them have to get punished for
it it seems like
all of them didn't do
what some of them did
but it seems that everybody wants them
all of them to be punished but i only
think that it's going to get worse if
they're doing police reform trying to
snatch away the guns and
it's going to go
it's going to go quick more crazy out
here
see so you know
that's the first time i saw the video
for the first time yeah i i never heard
of you before you know
you know and i'm in the music business
so so what's going on here is cashmere
is getting schooled at the moment right
right
this lady's saying he's got to be doing
more
she tries she try
[Music]
lawn and have picnics with my dog babies
that's it was nice it was really nice
why can't we play run catching kiss
bullets that's in the 70s cause i was
plenty bullets out here yeah
[Applause]
so to get this right the 70s were really
nice here it was nice then crack cocaine
crack came in right came in 80s 80s yeah
and it was dangerous in the 80s and then
90s was dangerous the 90 was just flat
out how is it now versus the 90s
it's all right now until ravers like
it's like a intercept it's like
everybody trying to figure it out right
now so different so it's different the
80s and 90s this was this was the most
terriblest place in brooklyn yes it was
where's the worst place now
the worst place now i say brownsville
yeah
yeah i agree so it changes like between
the neighborhoods and whatever everybody
everybody works
this sunday
at 10 a.m at 1091 fulton street we're
having the defeat depression event do
you see a huge increase in depression
this year yes we do yes we do we've at
the core line we have a helpline a
prayer line oh great we have a prayer
line people are calling they want to
commit suicide they're calling because
they can't eat they're calling because
their family members are dying but
there's it's a sadness that's happening
right now this world is cold right now
because of what's happening yeah so let
us regain let us find hope again
you can ask for me my name is wandra i
will be there wandra okay thank you you
have do you have to be religious no you
don't come as you are come as you thanks
swandra you're welcome sir beautiful
thank you good luck thank you bye-bye
let's talk to him real quick tell them
tell them where we're at how are you
doing tonight
who walked through sight listen
we
tell them where we are
murder capital east new york but beside
all that [ __ ] i'm the only ninja i'm the
only shinobi that get the march around
this [ __ ] this i go everywhere
now i'm saying shirt off chains out
jewelry blinging a regina
with the without it for real
he's the only guy that can go without
his shirt off he told he telling you
what that's freaking ripped listen to
what he said listen i'm the only
[ __ ] that get to running around
here like this now i'm saying yeah the
only one is bad man i mean because the
youth is [ __ ] up they're in the
[ __ ] position right now what i'm
saying
simple fact
you got the wrong [ __ ] giving
off the wrong type of chakra now i'm
saying i don't never want a misleading
type of what chakra that's the energy
yeah the wrong energy now i'm saying
this is divine what you put out you get
back so then you got [ __ ]
putting out bad juju bad juju come back
to you
i'm saying i don't want these kids to
ever get confused don't think they need
a [ __ ] bag at the age of
fifteen sixteen seventeen bag
money okay you earn that yeah yeah yeah
they need to finish school now i'm
saying find out who the [ __ ] they is and
i'm saying and make something they like
yeah i'm saying anything else beside
that ain't about a bag of [ __ ]
friends no i'm so it's different now the
values are different now values is all
[ __ ] up man that'd be a lot of [ __ ] is
[ __ ] up man pardon me for sweating you
know i'm coming from getting my breakout
i gotta hop it out but that's all right
it's all good y'all know how i want rip
mick now i'm saying but yeah man it's
just about the youth
no know the kings and the queens man now
i'm saying know the kings and the queens
on the board and it's not the one that's
on the board now i'm saying it's the
pawns that's gonna move up for the
future to become a valuable asset now
i'm saying so we all benefit now i'm
saying exactly we all benefit exactly is
this like a tight community
it can be it can be it can be then it
could be [ __ ] up because
you grew up with
[ __ ] blow your brains out for
some five you know what i'm saying and
then i i know it's that [ __ ] them beef
with half their whole life and they're
best friends now no i'm saying
so does anyone is it more guns to
resolve things or more fist fights to
resolve things you know you know the
answer to that i don't know
what you think let's take what you think
the last place where we they were saying
plaza they were saying fist fights yeah
fist fights on plaza but here i mean
when you were when you were in the inner
circle you might not if you have it have
to go there you might knuckle up but
usually that's not the case now i'm
saying people are going to shoot people
and that's just that's just the people
respect nonsense events and i said it
best people respect violence so i become
it
now i'm saying everybody that's the
universal language
now i'm saying every everybody
understand nobody might not understand
y'all i'm sorry yo don't let that happen
again yo look better luck next time you
don't understand when i say i'm a
puncher in your [ __ ] face yeah
we all speak that language i punch you
in your [ __ ] face you
understand exactly where i'm coming from
yeah that's a universal language and
that's
yeah now i'm saying respect is universal
though i'm saying something running
around if you're lacking that you
lacking common sense and you lacking
common sense you lacking life how long
you wanna go exactly moving like that
you can't we can't what do you think
what do you think's changed it stuff
like instagram
i mean social media got [ __ ] all-time
high that that's the everybody's
stunting for social media the violence
is from social media listen everything
is an all-time high everything's out of
control rap is out of control
the kids is out of control people that i
work with is out of control no i'm
saying i'm out of control
out of control behind that [ __ ]
camera
it's all insane right now
all we could do all we could do is just
try to be in sync with the matrix
because we in it
now i'm saying but how we gonna get
behind this [ __ ] if you fall for
everything
you stand for nothing you're going to be
a doorman
so how do you stay straight
i beat me i'm genuine i stay true to
myself i'm saying that's the best thing
listen the easiest thing is me being
it's me i wake up in the morning and
beat me i
but there's always respect
i give that out respect to everyone
everybody everybody equal to everybody
from the little man to the boss at the
top everybody give respect across the
right here everybody rep that
shout out the cash man no i'm saying
much success
saying shout out to everybody what's one
question one last question
what's the neighborhood need
well we need um communication
communication and resources yeah
communication and resources
communication with who yourselves are
with everyone with each other we need a
better understanding of each other each
other
each other in the neighborhood or each
other in new york first thing first it
gotta start with the thing
then it expands we gotta do our circle
in a circle then they right that's where
social media is cool though because i'm
gonna spread this message
i'm sure there's no one there's no way
someone would get into this neighborhood
without a guy like cash right how the
hell would i come around yeah nobody
cares that's the whole fact no but he
certified he could come through and do
it he's certified he's good now i'm
saying that real madrid thank you got it
we gotta call my mr james though
i'm a rapper too man a nice [ __ ]
out so i said that's for something else
that's something i miss your ways
i'm saying everybody don't know what it
is
mitchell ames
and that's what it is we out you know
what i'm saying yeah
love is love y'all love you my ninja
what do i do to get ripped what do i do
last question one more question how do i
get ripped like that what do i got to do
listen man hard work and dedication i'm
saying determination every day every day
every other day
that's what's up
he's charged he's charged he's shot
that's my boy mitchell aims man hood
legend we grew up together all that man
we gucci out here wherever i go we gucci
man peter you gucci i don't worry about
nothing
we don't worry about nothing god is
protecting [ __ ] me so what the
[ __ ] am i worried about me and my boy
peter chilling relaxing my boy going to
get an interview he with me he gucci
nobody going to do nathan
you don't even know where you at right
this is the og of the neighborhood we
got the chicken up here ready
that's really good i'm seeing a lot of
things that i'm not liking
how you doing
i'm
what's the youngest a kid has a gun
right now we gotta set the example so
they can follow
tell me